so as far as we can tell congressman
eric soyle dearly loves two things
having unnatural sex with chinese spies
and riding camels in the middle east
with no shirt on so we've got some news
for congressman swalwell tonight the
super bowl of camels is currently
underway in the united arab emirates
this is al dafra festival
it's the super bowl of camel pageantry
[Music]
each december 25 000 camels descend on
this remote area of the uae's western
region their owners come here from
across the gulf each with the hope their
camels will be crowned most beautiful
like beauty contestants winning camels
attract huge fan bases
some camels have their own hashtags on
instagram and fans will even write poems
about their beauty
famous camels also attract many high
cash offers
so you may not think camels are
beautiful but a lot of people in the
region do the problem is not all camels
are beautiful so some of them
get plastic surgery now right across the
border in saudi arabia there's a camel
beauty pageant underway right now and a
number of camels have been caught
getting botox
and touch-ups
is this appropriate for the dromedary
community is it ethical to give your
camel plastic surgery we've gone right
to the source on this forest galante is
a wildlife biologist he joins us tonight
for us thanks so much for coming on so
let's say you have a camel through no
fault of his own who's just unusually
unattractive and you think i'm gonna fix
this with a lip talk or an earpin
they can't give consent should that be
allowed
well tucker you could ask the same
question about your dog at home right
your dogs get cropped tails they get
their ears pinned and that's not
breaking news so
it's basically the same thing it's it's
a pet that you're altering
you know you make a really wise and
common sense point that i'm ashamed to
say never occurred to me now
how unattractive because i think from
the western perspective camels all kind
of look the same do you see a wide
variety in camel aesthetics
oh absolutely it's again going back to
the pet analogy it's just like your dog
at home some people have beautiful dogs
show quality dogs right others are less
fortunate you know here's the thing
tucker i live in southern california so
i've seen uh you know humps that have
been enlarged and lips that have been
blown up basically every day where i
live so it's not the most unnatural
thing in the world over here and now
we're pointing it out as being a problem
over there on camels and it's it's kind
of a little double edge there
that is such a smart point don't tell me
they're getting hump implants in saudi
arabia though
oh well you know different different
kinds of humps but that is a thing that
they're doing for their camels over
there they are doing botox fillers on
the lips they're stretching things
they're inflating the humps
they're doing all kinds of different
plastic surgeries to try and enhance the
beauty and the aesthetic of these camels
because the prize money is huge by the
way millions and millions of dollars
can they really quick i don't have a ton
of camel experience but some horrible
personalities on a camel nastiest animal
god created can they can they fix that
no i you know that they are typically
jerks they really are you're not wrong
about that but every now and then you
get a sweetheart and if you ask me
they're all beautiful if you if you draw
the short end of the stick and you get
an ugly camel love it for its
personality
foreskillancy really sorting out one of
the naughtiest problems
in the middle east tonight we appreciate
your coming on thank you so much